to present the award for best costume
design to world-renowned clothes [ __ ]
siz what close horses okay but I don't
think the plural of [ __ ] is horses he
directed a single man and she weighs a
single pound please welcome Tom Ford and
Sarah Jessica Parker
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
costumes are an integral piece in the
enormous puzzle of making a movie for an
actor it's the piece that makes you feel
really different from yourself it can be
as important in the building of a
character as rehearsal it is the
costumers attention to the detail that
gives us a window into who that
character is and by doing so becomes a
critical part of the storytelling here
are the nominees for best costume design
bright star costume design by Janet
Patterson cocoa before Chanel costume
design by Kathleen l'Italia The
Imaginarium of Doctor Parnassus costume
design by Monique Prudhomme 9 costume
design by Colleen Atwood The Young
Victoria costume design by Sandy Powell
and the winner is
the young Victoria sandy ha
[Music]
this is the third Academy Award an
eighth nomination for Sandy Powell she
also to come Oscar's for Shakespeare in
Love and The Aviator in this category
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow well I already have two of these I'm
feeling greedy I'd like to dedicate this
one to the costume designers that don't
do movies about dead monarchs or
glittery musicals the designers that do
the contemporary films and the
low-budget ones that actually don't get
us recognized and they should do and
they work as hard so this is for you but
I'm going to take it home tonight to
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you